so I think a lot of people would be
surprised to see a Palestinian who's a
Christian yes is there a tension in that
can you explain what it's like to be you
yes it's actually because I've been to
America once when I was there and I said
that I'm Palestinian Christians and they
how come you are Palestinian Christians
they don't know that in Palestine they
are Christian people Palestinian
Christians are exist since Jesus was
born the house that I lived in it it's
200 years old and it was my grand
grandfather who lived in this and my
grandfather and my father and me in the
same house in this area in Palestine
especially you can see Christians and
Muslims together living by side by side
and as a neighbors as we go to the
universities together we work together
we do everything together what aspects
of life is made difficult here because
of the tension between Israel and
Palestine yes
since Jesus was born it was occupied by
many till now I occupation after
occupations the best Palestine through
the Turkish the British Egyptian
Jordanian and that was the last is the
Israeli so there's quite a bit of
tension between the various religions
here yeah what gives you hope in the
future that's right yes because you know
Christianity Muslims and Judaism and
which is means
that all praise the Lord this makes me
feel very happy because I'm not a judge
to judge rather religious I'm I'm just
praying and God will judge everyone as
what he believes but the most important
thing between the three major religions
it's just to have most important to have
love